this will be the first time I have set
foot in a McDonald's in 12 years
say big moment here we are oh my god
I've had flashbacks already and this is
a drastically different place than
the McDonald's of 10 years ago doesn't
look like any McDonald's I've ever been
in it definitely looks better than those
clown passes they used to have nice
stone work I mean that's not cheap yeah
is it gonna taste drastically different
you're gonna let us know
smells hearty walked out of the doors
yeah it really is
Wow there's nothing in here that makes
you think this is a McDonald I think it
of a southern-style check except for the
way it smells in fact this is like I'm
loving it on the wall thank you very
much all right guys here's the goods
sure let's take a look okay are we ready
let's go enjoy
[Music]
glad to know some things haven't changed
in 12 years I'm having like mcpeet ESD
this looks very different this tastes
just as bad kid Merle used to have the
Styrofoam containers so now they've got
these that gives you the sense of like
minimal processing that's very green
look at this sandwich is called you know
artisan if you talk to a true artisan
and showed them this sure let's take a
look it's not like they have partisan
stuff back there and then regular stuff
one guy makes that sandwich all day
that's made by our artisan so then this
idea of like the simpler the better
they're able to kind of create this
health halo around the food by calling
it simple and you realize it doesn't
mean anything and look at this chicken
it's like a super nugget that's amazing
but also you got to love the fresh
cracked eggs cracked fresh in our
kitchen with two hands I feel better
already you know it's like the bare
minimum becomes the heights of like look
at what we've done they said they've
heard me yes we've heard you literally
talking about you we've heard yous
firlock and now look what we've done we
made a trifold brochure
[Music]